Scudder: Hi,
I'm Jeff Scudder,
and I'll be talking
with you today
about getting started
with the Python Library
for Google Data APIs.
The first thing
we're gonna need to do
is make sure that Python
is available on your system.
Let's get started.
Now, in many operating systems,
Python is already installed
by default.
To see if Python is available,
bring up a terminal
or command prompt
and type python-V to see
which version you're running.
if you're on Mac or Linux,
this is probably
already available.
But on a Windows system,
you'll need to install
Python yourself.
To install Python,
begin by downloading
from python.org.
You can find
the correct installer
for your version.
Once this is downloaded,
you can install as you would
any other Windows program.
I recommend downloading
Python 2.5, the latest version.
Anything that's version 2.2
or later
will work
with the Python Library,
but 2.5 is easier to set up.
Once you've installed Python,
we need to make sure that it
will run in the command line.
To do this, we need to edit
the Windows execution path.
You can edit the execution path
under the System settings,
so we'll go to Control Panel,
System.
Go to Advanced.
Click on Environment Variables
and find Path
under System variables.
Click the edit button
to modify it.
At the end of the path,
we need to add the location
where we've just installed
Python.
Once you're done,
click OK...
and OK again...
and OK one last time.
Now you should be able
to run Python
to see which version
you have on the command line.
Now that we can run Python
on the command line,
we need to make sure
that the dependencies
that the Python Library needs
are available on the system.
The main dependency that
the Python Client Library needs
is ElementTree,
which is used for parsing XML.
If you have Python version 2.5
or higher,
ElementTree is already available
on the system.
But if you're using an older
version like 2.4 or 2.2,
You'll need to install
ElementTree yourself.
You can download the ElementTree
Library on fbot.org.
To install ElementTree,
begin by downloading
the version
that's appropriate
for your system.
I chose to download
the zip file,
which I'll un-archive
and install
on the command line.
Now that we've downloaded
and unpacked ElementTree,
we're ready to install.
To install
the ElementTree Library,
go to the unzip directory...
and install using
python setup.py install.
Now that ElementTree
is installed,
you can optionally install
cElementTree,
which is a faster version
of ElementTree.
The installation process
for cElementTree
is the same as I've just shown
for ElementTree
where you use Python
setup.py install.
Now that we know
that ElementTree is installed
on our system,
we're ready to download
and install the Python Library.
From the Projects Home page,
which is at code.google.com/p
/gdata-python-client,
you can find
the latest download.
Download the zip file
and unpack it.
Once you've unpacked
this download,
we can install it
using a setup script
as we did earlier.
Simply type python setup.py
install to run the installer.
Now that we've installed
the Library,
we can make sure
that it's working
by running some of
the unit tests
that are bundled with it.
Go into the tests directory.
run_data_tests is a suite
that should execute quickly.
So type python run_data_tests
to run the test script.
If all the tests pass,
then you can be sure that you've
installed the Library correctly.
Now that we've installed
the Library,
let's get a general idea
for how it's structured.
You can browse the source code
here on code.google.com
on the Projects site,
gdata-python-client.
You can see here
that the source code
is divided up between atom
and gdata.
Gdata contains modules
for parsing XML
and for making HTTP requests
to Google servers.
There are two types of modules
in general.
In each of the product's
specific directories,
you'll find a module
that's responsible
for parsing XML
and one that's responsible
for talking to Services.
You can browse
the source code as well.
There's also auto-generated
documentation
available online
which you can find
from the Project Home page.
If we wanted to, for example,
take a look at the different
Data Model classes
that are available
for a blogger,
you could view this
auto-generated documentation.
You can see here
that we have things like
BlogFeeds and CommentFeeds.
If you wanted to take a look
at the Service Module,
which shows the HTTP requests
that can be made,
you would click
on Blogger Service,
take a look at some
of the different methods.
For example,
Blogger Service has methods
that help you add comments,
add posts,
delete comments, etcetera.
Now let's get an idea
for how to use the Library
by looking
at an interactive sample.
I'm going to start
by reading the titles
from the
Google Data APIs Blog
and then show
how you can post a new blogpost
to one of your blogs.
From the command line,
we'll begin by running
the Python Interpreter.
The first thing
we'll need to import
is the module for Blogger.
We'll also import
the atom module,
which will help us construct
the elements that we're sending
to the Blogger Service.
Now we'll need
to create a client
which is responsible for talking
to the Google servers.
Now that we have our client,
we can use our user name
and password
to authenticate
with Google servers
to make sure
that we have permission
to post our new blog posts
later on.
Now that we have our client,
we're ready to get the feed
of blog posts
from the Google Data
APIs Blog.
We'll paste in the URL
of the blog feed.
And now we should have
our feed object.
You can see that the feed
contains multiple entries.
We get 25 entries by default,
and we can print out
the titles of each entry
as follows.
You can see
that we've printed the title
of the 25 most recent posts
to the Google Data APIs Blog.
Now let's show adding
a new post to our blog.
I have a Test Blog here
that I'd like to add
a new post to.
To begin, I'll construct
a new atom entry.
And I'll give it a title.
I'll also give it some content.
Now that we have our entry,
we're ready to post it
to the blog.
We'll tell our client
to perform a post,
sending our entry
to the blog's feed URL.
Now we have our new entry...
We can see the ID
of the new blog post.
And we can also see
that our blog post
is now on the blog.
Now that we've seen this
simple example with Blogger,
let's take a look at where
you can find more resources
to use other
Google Data Services.
There's a list
of supported services
on the Project Home page.
Each of these lists a detailed
step-by-step documentation
for using the various
Google Data Services.
For example, to show more
of the things that you could do
with the Blogger API
and the Python Library,
take a look
at the Python Developer's Guide
on code.google.com.
The Google Data
Python Client Library
is also an open source project
with an active developer
community.
If you find a bug,
or have suggestions,
or ideas to improve
the Library,
feel free to post it
in our discussion group.
So that's it.
Thanks for watching,
and happy coding.